two-time Oscar winner Jack Nicholson
this year the Academy Board of Directors
has voted to present the honorary Oscar
to one of the movies great visionaries
Michelangelo Antonioni
most movies celebrate the ways we
connect with one another the films of
this master mourn the failures to
connect in the empty silent spaces of
the world he is found metaphors that
illuminate the silent places of our
hearts and found in them to a strange
and terrible beauty austere elegant
enigmatic and haunting
to that
ladies and gentlemen mr. and mrs. mr.
and mrs. Michael Angelo Antonia
I think it's it's very beautiful to
receive this award and also it's very
beautiful to receive all this love and
sometimes words are not needed because
of this love Michelangelo always went
beyond words to meet silence the mystery
and the power of silence but tonight I
think he wants to say
he says Grazia thank you
more stars in more comedy with Hugh
Grant Andie MacDowell and a performance
by Elton John stay with the Oscars